[Música]
salud tendría hito américa de france 24
me acompaña en el estudio marina sardina
marina bienvenida feliz mañana del lunes
hoy precisamente 6 de junio se celebra
el día mundial de los pacientes
trasplantados una fecha promovida por la
organización mundial de la salud que
busca entonces concientizar sobre la
importancia del aro de la donación de
órganos como medio para salvar las vidas
marinas buenos días raúl así es hoy se
conmemora este día que tiene como
objetivo pues fomentar la cultura de la
donación de órganos y dar así una
segunda oportunidad de vida a estos
pacientes que tienen el trasplante como
último arte alternativa de vida también
vemos que durante la pandemia hubo un
fuerte retroceso en las donaciones y los
trasplantes de órganos para hablar de
este tema nos acompaña a carlos perez el
infectólogo de la universidad nacional
de colombia buenos días doctor cuál es
la importancia de este día y cuáles son
las condiciones para que una persona
pueda ser donante de órganos
recordemos que una persona que dona un
órgano de una vida y es un proceso de
solidaridad en muchas de las
enfermedades crónicas como una
enfermedad renal las enfermedades
pulmonares post
enfermedades cardiacas con una donación
se pueden salvar más de tres vidas y
pueden estos órganos ayudarle a personas
jóvenes a que sigan sobreviviendo éste
es un día que se conmemora esa
recordación de la solidaridad de que
todos somos donantes y todos
potencialmente somos donantes y cuando
fallece moss pueden ser dar dar vida a
otras personas que lo necesitan esos
órganos para que puedan tener una vida
saludable y no lleno de máquinas y de
medicamentos doctor de salud o buen día
le pregunta entonces los tipos de
trasplantes que son más comunitaria
mundial y por qué
aun lo que más se trasplanta en órganos
sólidos es el riñón seguir el pulmón y
el corazón en la enfermedad renal es una
enfermedad crónica que es muy prevalente
y terminan los pacientes en máquinas de
diálisis y estas máquinas de diálisis
son de tres o cuatro veces por semana
sesiones de 3 o 4 horas cuando una
persona recibe un riñón se quita esa
máquina de diálisis es tal vez el
trasplante que jamás ha salvado vidas es
el más frecuente digamos que es el más
accesible y por eso todos somos donantes
y todos debemos ayudar y colaborar que
si tenemos una familiar en una situación
de exceso voluntariamente no acercarnos
para orientarnos cómo podemos ser
donantes de órganos en el momento de
nuestro fallecimiento doctor según el
observatorio mundial de donación y
trasplantes en 2020 se trasplantaron 129
mil 681 órganos en todo el mundo pero
sin embargo la pandemia pues redujo
estas cifras drásticamente cuéntanos qué
consecuencias o cómo impactó la pandemia
de kobe 19 a este tipo de operaciones
que por lo general ya con largas listas
de espera
si la pandemia nos dejó una segunda
pandemia que son las enfermedades
crónicas no atendidas una de ellas muy
grande es la renal porque porque los
pacientes siguieron en diálisis a raíz
del coi hubo más pacientes en diálisis
lo mismo que más pacientes con falla
pulmonar pero no hubo donantes y no hubo
equipos no estamos preparados los
equipos para hacer esos trasplantes sin
embargo se hicieron esfuerzos
heroicos para seguir tras plantando en
medio de la pandemia pero ahora se
necesita esa solidaridad reactivar la
donación recordar la donación como un
acto de vida y si necesitamos muchos más
donantes y que haya más activación de
más centros de receptores de órganos
sobre todo reunión renal pulmonar y de
corazón doctor también hace unas semanas
los doctores del hospital universitario
de zúrich lograron trasplantar con éxito
un hígado conservado durante tres días
fuera del cuerpo humano un órgano que
por lo general requiere que no pase más
de 12 horas fuera de nuestro cuerpo como
se logró esta operación y cuáles son los
avances en la ciencia entonces para
mejorar así los trasplantes y facilitar
las donaciones
hemos hablado algunos trasplantes pero
el trasplante se puede trasplantar casi
todos los órganos el hígado el intestino
se pueden hacer trasplantes socios y se
puede hacer una gran cantidad de
trasplantes de retina de córnea que son
los más frecuentes
y recordemos que esta técnica lo que
permite es conservar intacto el hígado
para que pueda ser llevado a un donante
esto digamos para cosas de transporte de
donación es muy importante y marca un
hito de lo que puede hacer el futuro de
la donación de órganos con esa
preservación del órgano extra corporal
por más tiempo esto permitiría que se
puedan hacer trasplantes en más largas
distancias y donde haya otro tipo de
transporte por ejemplo para poder llevar
el doctor jacques y en américa latina'
de argentina cuba brasil están liderando
este tipo de operaciones y de donaciones
detrás de órganos que retos tiene la
región a la hora de pues incentivar está
este tipo de donaciones también pues
teniendo en cuenta las fuertes
desigualdades sanitarias que sufre la
red latinoamericana
en nuestra región tenemos primero un
gran reto que la pedagogía la dar un
órgano donar un órgano es donar vida no
quitarle y nosotros después de
fallecidos podemos ayudarle a las otras
personas a que tengan una vida saludable
es importante recordar que si una
persona con un órgano no está quitando
se le nada te está ofreciendo una vida
para los demás y nosotros debemos
incentivar esa donación antes de las
cremaciones antes de los entierros para
que esos riñones hígados córneas huesos
e hígados todo esto pueda ser utilizado
para sobre todo personas jóvenes que lo
necesitan es un llamado la solidaridad a
la pedagogía ya que todos nos
sensibilicemos que donar es dar vida
para los demás
pues doctor gracias como siempre por su
tiempo por acompañarnos nuestro espacio
de salud en directo américa gracias
marina también por toda la información y
como siempre acompañarnos en esta
sección de salud de directo américa
pasamos ahora a saludar a nuestro
segundo invitado el día